pharmaceutical industry back in the day
I was always very frustrated by Russia
Constantine it takes to convert new
science into new medicines to patients
this is an incredibly expensive industry
much of an expense much reasons we pay
so much for drugs is actually cost of
failure it's actually because many ideas
don't work
so we looked at this and I concluded
actually it's very much a information
industry actually and if we think of it
that way we can actually then think
about how we can use the latest
techniques in Information Technology
such as artificial intelligence machine
learning event to improve the way we
handle the data to improve a way we
think about decision making in fact
that's what the whole sort of r d
process is in a pharmaceutical it's very
much around data and decision making
accenti event was set up as truly an AI
first company but how we can change the
way the r d process is is conducted
think about how AI can be applied truly
end to end from the whole process of how
you designed a drug how you develop it
Etc what we fundamentally see then is
that in doing so creating a more
overarching approach approach to how AI
can change the process of r d you also
potentially can end up with much better
drugs as well it's really about how you
can design the right drug
and select the right patient for that
drug and overall We Believe actually
that can change actually economics of
the industry
of each of those areas as to how AI
um the application of AI can
improve that process give you two
examples actually the first one is how
AI can help us select the right patient
actually how we can improve patient
outcomes a clinical trial which we
published in Regional cancer Discovery
just uh last year we believe it's the
first time in an AI machine Learning
System had been shown to improve
clinical outcomes and oncology
what we had developed was a system where
we would take samples from patients with
blood cancer do single cell analysis and
that means actually looking at
individual cells about and then seeing
how it responds to over 100 different
types of drugs far more than you could
ever give a patient to travel through
each of the patients enrolled onto trial
were basically late stage patients
they've gone through maybe five six
seven lines of therapy with very little
left to to treat them with what we found
then when we use the AI system to really
analyze all the different ways the
different cell types your cancer cell
your immune cells your healthy cells
would respond you want to distinguish
you want to find a drug that will kill
the cancer cell but not to kill your
immune cells so what we found then by
using the complex biology of this you
needed sort of AI systems to really
analyze the Single Cell details about of
different drug responses but in soon so
then in doing so then we were able then
to rank all these drugs and say for this
individual patient this particular drug
is the one you should recommend to
prescribe truly personalized medicine
the results of our trial was in the
control group about 15 people
um then within about a year everybody
was progressing
within the group I was treated with
drugs recommended by the AI system about
25 of patients were still
progression-free survival
after four years
and this was actually looking at a whole
range of drugs using existing
pharmacopias is called the existence of
a medicine cabinet between which
particular drug could be useful for them
and we would find things like a drug
which would potentially have failed a
clinical trial for a particular blood
cancer indication actually was the right
drug for that patient because in the
clinical trial they wouldn't necessarily
select in the right patients to do that
that's why often clinical trials fails
often due to statistics have necessarily
got the right patients being selected
for a trial so that had a what's called
an objective response rate of around 55
percent a hazard ratio of 0.53 these are
excellent statistics for a new medicine
even but this was a new process to help
us get the most of even our existing
medicine cabinet
to help sort of
um patients live longer and but progress
in free survival just longer so just on
that it says pause on that for a second
um in the first evidence session all of
an session that we took
um one of our Witnesses said um this is
uh this is not new this is this is maths
basically
um and isn't what you've described
looking at the the effect of a
particular drug on a particular patient
what medical research has always done
um and and you analyze its impact so so
what is the difference that AI is the
difference now is the complexity of a
biology which we now analyzing now when
we take uh the looking at individual
single cells not just gross amounts of
tumor uh looking at the statistics of
then hundreds and thousands of internal
cells and the distributions of a
different responses we now also looking
at how we integrate all the different
old mixed data single cell sequencing as
possible single cell transcriptomics for
single cell phenomics of how I respond
to integrate all of this data and to
distinguish between particularly is
about a cancer cell and is that an
immune cell and is that a healthy cell
and how we respond differently that's
where sort of computer vision machine
learning become incredibly important in
helping us distinguish this out this is
something that you uh um it's of a scale
which a human sort of uh um
pathologist would never be able to sort
of explore this right so that's the
point isn't it so it's using data that
is there
um but it's you're saying that it's
there are limits to the unit to the
cognitive or computational ability of of
human individuals and so the computing
power
allows more to be seen in in the data is
that absolutely and also the relevance
of that as well you know many times
people would do sort of tests and
laboratories on of um cell lines and you
know most models which actually have
very little relevance to human disease
what you find when you can do these kind
of detailed analysis which actually only
machine learning is capable have allowed
us to do is that we can truly do it on a
personalized approach we've been talking
about personalized medicine for nearly
20 years well we are starting to see now
as the first Trials of it truly
happening that is this particular drug
for that particular individual at this
particular point in time
that's it's a it's an enabler and it
enables us then to take what would be a
uh the intellectual framework that we
had for 20 years
but now actually put it into real
practice that's what machine learning is
allowing us to do it's a complexity of
the data which we're now Gathering which
you are capable of gathering as you know
from your other investigations into the
genome Revolution and how cheap it is
now potentially to gather genomic data
but was she a wealth and depth and
breadth of our data is beyond as you
said sort of human cognition to
understand how we would analyze it this
is where the machine learning approaches
we're using actually allow us to do this
okay uh and just um one final one for me
then Stephen has a supplementary
question on this
um you mentioned that the control group
was 15 people
um that seems quite a small group why
why so the whole study was uh over 70
sort of people altogether you know uh
first investigational study actually uh
we've just set up uh just announced
yesterday I expanding this trial
approach with Charity Hospital in Berlin
taken this further this was the very
first sort of uh
uh publication of this approach so what
do you expect to see now is more trials
further development of his technology as
we take it forward
but this technology is not just used for
the patient today the second example we
also use this before you want to take an
example uh Professor please let me uh
bring Stephen and her a question on what
you've said so far sorry yes it was
going back to one of the point earlier
points you made which was about the use
of failed drugs drugs that have failed
previously at trial because perhaps they
were too specific to a certain cell type
um what do you do with that information
once you have it and does that mean that
there is an argument to revisit lots of
other drugs that have failed at
first trial second trial stage because
they could potentially be personalized
and the second part of that is is there
a huge cost involved with this because
we always assume that personalized
medicine is very expensive medicine is
that the case no I think the the
higher responsibility we can get
obtained fundamentally creates a much
more beneficial economic situation I
think for Healthcare systems and for
patients I said the real cost is the
cost of failure the cost of waste that's
if you can match a right drug to a
patient you actually start to reduce
that waste for the benefit of patients
for the benefit of society yeah and so
what do we see that is yes there
probably are
a number of drugs which have potentially
failed because they were in the wrong
patient groups never we've ever tested
and the more we can then precisely
Define which patients should be
prescribed that particular drug then
overall we should start to see in time
potentially success rates start to
improve this is a key feature then about
how you can use this technology I just
described not just potentially to help
late stage cancer patients today but
also to help us design better clinical
trials and select better patients for a
trials this is what we do moving new
drugs which have been generated by AI
now headed into the clinic novel
medicines is that we now take the wealth
of omics data that has been generated
and really help distinguish their end
between what we believe are very
sophisticated sort of biomarkers as they
called Gene signatures to say that we
believe that that patient group is much
more likely to respond than this other
Patient Group and this goes beyond sort
of the first generation of genomic
medicine first generation of John
mcmenson you might be aware of we you
might have a particular mutation in a
Cancer and you design a particular drug
for that mutation but in many cases even
if we target in that particular Patient
Group you still might only get a 30
response rate there's something else
obviously going on in biology but beyond
just that single mutant and this is what
this more sophisticated approach but you
can only really it's only really enabled
by the use of machine learning to
interrogate and understand the wealth of
data that we now are able to generate
from patients Etc and just a quick
follow-up which is all clarification
perhaps which is that where there are
drugs that previously have failed and
therefore not been taken forward
presumably it's in the interests of the
companies that developed that is to
revisit there
Bank of uh
development research are they starting
to do that or not that's why I suppose
I'm trying to get to are has what you've
said motivated people to revisit
potentially this is only potential
absolutely The Cutting Edge you know
right so these results are only
published a few months ago Etc so it is
certainly possible I think any company
would want to see that could be money
they've invested into a generation of at
IP potentially benefit patients so I
believe actually there is a new
opportunity to be created around provide
matchmaking so to say identifying the
right drug for right patient and this I
believe fundamentally will help us
improve you know the the odds in the
clinic Etc brilliant thank you thanks
says you know I think Carol want you to
come in just again just a slight
clarification or if you could help us if
a drug has previously failed a trial how
do you persuade a regulator to
um allow that to be used again in your
child if it's failed for safety then if
one has generated new data showing their
dad it actually is an effective medicine
then it passes for the normal regulated
process as usual you know if it is
failed for other reasons you know such
as then it's a very sort of different
situation necessarily considered here
we're talking really about uh efficacy
does a drug work for patients uh we I'm
not yet discussing about so these aren't
drugs that are field for safety no these
are just very efficacy yes exactly did
the statistics of a trial
that's fake thank you it's very
important certification
um you're going to describe your second
uh example yes the second use of AI is
around how AI can make the processes of
creating new medicines much more
efficient you might be aware of seeing
the public imagination right now concept
of generative AI chat GDP Wally Etc
mid-journey in the artistic department
but actually the use of generative AI in
chemistry and Drug Discovery accent has
been developing for nearly a decade now
since we first published our research in
nature and what we see now is that if we
work with a sort of our expert drug
Hunters using these generative
algorithms basically to help us design
molecules towards very specific
objectives to make the drugs potentially
more safer this is about Precision
Engineering you should think of a drug
not as little white tablet but actually
as a Precision engineer technology it is
the result the atoms are arranged in
that molecule are the result of
potentially billions of other decisions
that could have been made about what it
could be and in fact to reduce that
search space down AI allows us then to
search that and reduce it far more
efficiently Give an example we've now
developed about seven prototype drugs
several of them in patient clinical
trials several others heading towards uh
clinical trials it was called an IND
enabling studies
and what we see now is that on average
we've made our own 90 through our
compounds on average about 250 compounds
per project compared to around two and a
half thousand compounds that would be
usually in a pharmaceutical industry in
a sort of drug optimization project this
vendors implications for cost
implications for time uh but also we
believe potentially much more precise
molecules being designed as well so we
are now seeing repeatable
um evidence that the use of
computational approaches AI approaches
in drug design can potentially help us
create a more efficient drug Discovery
process that's what's really exciting
about this and what you do then is to
think about combining that kind of
generative approach to potentially a
more efficient approach way of drug
discovery with the approach I just
described a few minutes ago about select
and also a right patient that is what
we're trying to do bring all those
together into a sort of end-to-end
process and that's what I see is
multiple benefits of the application of
AI event across that whole industry
Spectrum good excellent so it's um being
more precise about how you can Target
drugs to people and then to in drug
Discovery to to design drugs based on
problems that you want to absolutely
it's an information problem of data and
decision making good well let me turn to
my colleague starting with Rebecca Long
Bailey and then Aaron Bell thank you you
mentioned um efficiency in the
development of new treatments and also
that there was an emerging evidence base
obviously this is a new area of uh of
science what but why do you think that
the larger pharmaceutical companies
um have been reassured enough to make a
significant bet on AI in this field yes
so of um when when I founded accentio
when we first did work uh it was well
before AI was fashionable uh but I we
had a sort of a deep belief that this
was a way forward for the industry I
think actually now with the evidence
base that's been accumulating drugs
moved on to the clinic the kind of
clinical trial I described earlier
called Excel one is now given a
pharmaceutical industry you know
increased confidence to think about
making these Investments and they too
are also thinking about Investments not
just in research but across the whole
pipeline you know particularly in
commercial and marketing as well as in R
D
um so it is a of um I think a concerted
effort of investment and if you speak to
a company's AstraZeneca GSK in the UK as
well you'll see that they've been hiring
you know quite a number of data
scientists and AI scientists as well I
think one advantage of a company like
accentia has is that for us it's not
plan B it's plan a in fact it's our only
plan but we believe that this is a way
to reinvent the process and I think the
true advantages of AI is about not just
adding it to an existing process
but actually think about how we can
reinvent a process for example if you
think about finance and the use of
computers and finance
um we didn't actually you know put
robots into a High Street to show caches
as a bank teller it completely re-vented
a process where now you have all your
phone uh banking is now done on your
mobile phone Etc if I have an app so
it's a wave end to think about how you
might re-imagine and re-engineer your
entire processes that I think is the
exciting thing actually that's going to
be I think some of the interesting
competitive interplays between the
smaller Insurgent companies like
accentia and in the larger companies as
well but important thing to remember
that in this ecosystem is a lot of
collaboration as well we collaborate
with a large number big Pharma companies
like sanofi BMS Etc and that's important
really it's about actually each company
bring away different skill sets uh big
companies are very good
commercializationally development uh
companies like accenti I think are
actually a very good discover very early
development stage
on the issue of data protection that's a
huge concern in the emergence of AI
within Healthcare how do you think AI
systems can be provided with the data
that they need to improve in a way that
innovates whilst also maintaining
adequate data protection I think that
question is at the heart actually of
what this committee is investigating
particularly in healthcare we're already
in a very well regulated industry as it
should be
and I think actually we have not only
have the regulations of the of Health
Care and the ethics of running clinical
trials and also the safety regulations
for development Pharmaceuticals we also
of course have all the data governance
and priority issues as well that we need
to take into account so we have a myriad
of overlapping regulatory Frameworks as
well to to which to to work within
what we're trying to do here is to think
about how we can make a very expensive
industry much more efficient in the long
run and that I believe is for benefit of
patients and bringing more and better
medicines forward and also for benefit
of Health Care Systems and governments
ultimately as well so I think one of the
things to consider then is how in the UK
can we make advances that AI is seen
potentially as enabler for a benefit of
society and the risk is actually not
applying AI in these places I believe
rather than applying it so I think
actually you um you already have a very
strong framework in terms of data
governance and confidentiality and
ethics Frameworks within those multiple
regulatory Frameworks I described
but at the same time the UK has also
been an amazing place for generating
data you know and what we've done with
our sequence and initiatives what we've
done with UK biobank these have been
World leading in providing large data
environments actually that can attract
Innovation to the UK as well
um one of the concerns of course is that
even if you try to regulate data as we
do here in the UK and you remove names
and details from from records that
you're using as part of a data set
certain indicators might still point to
a particular individual whether it was
the date that they had a heart attack on
for example and and that would flag them
up and breach their data essentially how
would you try to overcome those sorts of
data protection breaches
oh that's uh that's Beyonds that I would
say the every expertise for myself
actually so I will answer how I think
about the systems I think um
it is entirely possible to think about
um in the use and ethics of the data
that we generate in particularly as you
think about NHS Hospital data going
forward and there have been a number of
initiatives actually are trying to be do
this in an ethical fashion actually and
I think they actually are totally
supported and I think I should get the
framework right for that and actually
think about in terms of not just sort of
a piecemeal approach about small
individual companies maybe take in a few
Hospital trusts human via data but
actually consider it as a national
strategy it is actually one of the huge
potential data resources that the UK
have you know it's equivalent to almost
oil in the Saudi desert but you still
need to mine it to get uh drill it out
to get the value and in fact the unified
Healthcare System we have in the UK and
the data records actually could go with
it is actually potentially of huge value
to the UK as well so
um if you can therefore think of a right
regulatory framework that would allow
you to be comfortable with that and
think about it as a national strategy
seen this as a key data resource
actually I think this is a very
important sort of potential source of
wealth for the UK because it can act
potentially as a Honeypot event for
Innovation and to attract companies to
the UK to to use the data
another issue that
the bias in data sets how would your
company try to overcome bias
so of um in the data sets we're looking
at which is particularly looking at
individual patients
um the bias we think of is uh you know
are we making sure that we can truly
understand that this particular sample
of cancer we have is representative of
your entire cancer so we think of Bison
a very very different way very
individualized uh in terms of societal
bias such as you as you alluding to the
key way is to think about how we create
sort of larger data sets and actually
then of um make sure that we are
sampling across the entire population
correctly uh make sure that
underrepresented groups are included
actually in the healthcare records and
how we exploit in it that's a really key
important thing
there always actually potential event of
Designing those systems to incorporate
and understand bias one of the key
things we deal with is a fact that drug
Discovery is both a big data problem but
also a small data problem actually we
know very little sometimes about started
things and therefore techniques what we
call Active Learning have been vital the
question is asking ourselves you know
what bit of data should you collect next
to actually improve your models and
active learning techniques actually
could be one way to think about how you
understand the bias in your models and
actually then deliberately to go out to
seek particular data sets to improve
your model in a certain way
final question on transparency and can
the AI systems used by businesses like
yours ever be fully transparent and
explainable or are they by definition
black boxes no they're not by definition
of black boxes it depends entirely in
architecture one is uh building the
systems upon we ourselves like to really
understand the Providence of
understanding a prediction so where now
chemists are looking at a design and say
why is the suggested you know we design
a molecule in a particular way we can
trace that back then to saying because
actually data set says that actually for
this particular Target or this
particular side effect to avoid it you
have this design so that actually
explainability as you would call it
connecting the dots between the
prediction and the date of Allegra
prediction I think it's vitally
important for like understanding in
science as much it is for the General
Public
it is not inherent at any AE systems are
unexplainable I think actually it
depends entirely on a specific
architecture and I think if
explainability is a key part of a of the
solution that you want you need to take
that architectural concerns into account
in the design of the system right from
start
thank you very much just from that point
you started your evidence by saying that
the the purpose for the deployment of um
AI was that things were beyond the
computation under the cognitive power of
individuals but you've just said there
that actually everything uh you you want
everything to be explainable you want to
see those connections sure it's a
tension between those no it's not it's
the size of a space you know uh for
example
um
there are potentially billions of
decision trees one could create you know
in a generative system to understand uh
where we could go
Whitlow knows down van to find out this
is the solution that we now have
prioritized and decided this is the
molecule we now want to make has been
generated but then understanding about
why individual predictions come from why
is it highly in individual models can be
then traced back so it's a case of
um the sheer scale of the of um
approach and decisions and amount of
data which we're ingesting is beyond I
would say human cognition but actually
once we then sort of come to a solution
that we want to find then tracing it
back actually then is a much smaller
problem potentially to end to understand
and so yes you could say ah yes I can
see that Insight I can see whether it's
connected but actually that is
effectively the needle in the haystack
between everything else that you could
have got lost in
is it not the case that um in with some
medicines actually we don't know why
they work how they they work we we know
they do and they proceed without an
expression having been tested for safety
and all the rest of things
um so you're setting a higher threshold
than actually is the case for you know
for kind of many drugs that we've used
for a long time in fact what I described
earlier the XL1 trial Embraces what you
just said it's actually saying what
we're looking for at the cellular level
is the effect I'm not saying how it
works or what we just want to say does
this drug work for you that is the
question we asking we're not asking yet
why it works for you that we can then
start a workout by integration of all of
the other types of all mixed data and
that sort of back propagation to
understand that is exactly what we're
doing to find new drug targets to find
out is there a new drug Target we could
go after from that result from you are
sort of fantastic it's not a requirement
to to explain it is no it's not a
requirement to isolate the um absolutely
for a drug to be approved it doesn't
necessarily need to know how it works
what we need to show is the evidence
that it works thank you everybody thank
you thank you Mr Hopkins um you've said
it yourself in quotes we need to change
the way drugs are invented have you got
there yet or are you still on that
Journey we it's a continuous Journey
because what you want to do never stop
trying to improve your processes I think
what we have got now is the first
examples where the use of these
specially learning techniques with our
sort of expert drug Hunters is starting
to show now that we are producing I
think you know Precision engineered
molecules in a way that is I think far
more efficient than traditionally has
been the case and we will continue to do
that we continue to develop those
systems where accenti has got to now is
asking a question how do we scale how do
we then take what is potentially at the
Vanguard of this sort of technology and
ask a question how would all drugs be
invented this way so where we are in our
company now is in the period of scaling
the company scaling a technology event
to apply to many many more projects you
described earlier how you're looking at
a tenth of the number of compounds as
before 250 to two and a half thousand uh
how much have you learned from Google's
Alpha fold and what they did with
protein is that relevant to what you're
doing is yours more about chemical
compounds rather than proteins I
appreciate they're all chemicals but is
that is that learning that you've
absorbed into what you do yes it's part
of what we do uh we think of it as an
end-to-end process so that's a
particular solution to one particular
important problem we've already been
incorporating that technology into our
early stage approaches actually but also
taking some of the learnings of that
actually and applying it to other
Technologies and techniques for example
how how could we take that kind of
artificial intelligence framework and
actually can we apply it and develop it
to be faster against things like how you
design antibody drugs using that kind of
approach of AI and that's where we are
now working as well as a company we want
to now think about how you can design
antibodies using AI as well as design
small molecules thank you and um do you
think we'll eventually have a drug
designed entirely by AI or is always
going to be the AI is there to shrink
the space and then hand it over to the
the more traditional approach or you
think we could get to a situation where
literally the whole thing is handled by
AI from start to finish eventually I
believe that's theoretically possible
but at the moment it is incredibly vital
the interplay and this is important for
all of the industries that develop in AI
the interplay between the human and the
systems a good example of this is of the
observations of Gary Chris farmwaf
actually and how AI has been using chess
so a past decade Etc or two decades
nearly now what's called Centaur chess
actually and what he really found is
that well systems could make the average
chess player much more proficient games
could become tactically Flawless
you could then have an average player or
Master you know start to go computer
Grandmaster even if you're both using
algorithms because they slaves in
different applications and systems the
real Advantage comes from
combination of human skills and human
creativity with the computer power of AI
an integrated into new processes so it's
humans plus machine plus process
is actually what is the key thing you
need to think about if you want to
revolutionize industry I think
you said it would be theoretically
possible and it might happen that it
would be purely AI what sort of date
would we be talking about on that if if
it was possible in the next 10 years or
the next 20 or next 50. in terms of uh
drugs which are moving forward to a
clinic which have either had you know
generative AI systems involved in a
design very closely if that's already
happening today yes you know and of
course we still have uh you know human
experts guiding and driving the process
human drug Hunter knows what they want
they know what good looks like so to say
um I don't want to put a date on it yet
but what I would say is that it is an
active mission of Accenture our mission
is to solve drug Discovery and I I
believe if you follow this logically
through follow the strategies through
it's entirely possible to do it
thank you um Frank Nestle who's the
chief scientific officer at snowy who
you'll know obviously said has said the
use of AI in medical research is reliant
on computer power algorithms and data
and that the biggest need for
improvement relates to data do you agree
with that what are the shortcomings of
the data at the moment and how are they
being addressed
I think
there is still a lot to be done in terms
of other performance I can particularly
referring to your last question uh as we
particularly move up levels of thinking
of uh particularly how you incorporate
human creativity and human strategy into
processes this is the real value add
that human drug discovers bring in terms
of data that's why we as a company you
know 40 of our staff we employ are
experimental biologists and laboratory
generating data you need a high quality
data to generate your algorithms that's
why sort of large data generation
initiatives as I mentioned earlier UK
biobank genome England Etc are
incredibly important National Assets
potentially in this space and where we
are focusing our data generation is
working with hospitals working with
clinicians uh gather involves cancer
samples because with the wealth of
information there that can be discovered
uh within that is incredible every time
we invent a new technology every time we
invent a new kind of omics allows us to
have a new insight event into apology
but not omics by itself is is not enough
you want to integrate it with all the
other data but you also can generate
this is why for us as a company the
ability then to consider
um
how you can access patient samples and
then develop sort of machine learning
deep learning driven analysis of our
samples I believe actually this is where
the key advances will come in
personalizing medicine you just talked
about the importance of wide
repositories of data that you and other
firms can rely on presumably you
generate a lot of your own data whilst
doing the work is that all proprietary
or do you have mechanisms for sharing
that and making it openly available no I
thought about proprietary information
and for many of the arrangements we have
ethical Frameworks we work with with
various hospitals that is as it has to
be as well actually
there are potentially opportunities as
well of thinking of how do you gather
this data on a national basis actually
potentially again this could be an
important role for the NHS actually it's
there's data Beyond even the of the
electronic health records that have been
talked about earlier in terms of how we
think about pathology biopsies Etc can
be digitalized and start to be provided
into a framework huge money out of
wealth to the benefit of individual
patients that could be generated
we discussed this in a previous inquiry
that the NHS is a huge resource for
firms like yours what's the fair price
for you to pay to the NHS for the data
that they have
um I can't really give a comment on how
do we love to sit down and work it as we
do but the main thing we work it out for
example yesterday we announced a
research collaboration with uh one of
the biggest cancer hospitals in Germany
called charity
there is a two-way relationship it's not
about money it's about how do you bring
the data and the Technologies back to
the patients that's what Physicians
really want they want the data to
understand how do they treat their
patients and so we actually see it as a
two-way relationship actually
thank you thank you very much
um
thank you very much Professor Hopkins
it's very interesting can I ask who are
your current customers
so our current customers are everyone
from the large Pharma companies people
like sanofi BMS
small biotechs
um academic groups as well we are
working with and of course ourselves
and um
when when you're doing this research
you've talked a lot about the the
ability the capacity of AI to look at
all the different options and I think
use the phrase needle in the haystack
um
would you consider then the AI is an
augmentation tool or will ultimately
remove humans from drug research right
now it is a tool used by humans humans
really understand the strategy we want
to follow and as I said know what good
looks like in terms of developing a drug
we are thinking an exploring of how
actually you bring much more a strategic
level into the long terms of development
of these Technologies it's not about
replacing humans it's about how do we
make people more productive
and so I mean
it's not about replacing humans but if
your company does drug research so much
better than a whole pile of um humans
who are working in the same field surely
ultimately it will replace humans
if we ever got to that point
um the other benefit of society of
course would be uh potentially many more
medicines being available to people it
would potentially be we then started to
create a healthier Workforce we then
have other economic benefits to the
patient and Society uh potentially the
impact on health care costs as well so I
think the the long-term benefits of
taking a inefficient uh and costly
approach to creating sort of I think
vital medicines
is actually in society's benefit in the
long term if we can do that
um so what are the risks to replacing
the inefficient and costly humans
it's not about replacing humans and
sense but how do you make your drug
Discovery scientists more productive for
example you could be a drug Discovery
scientist in a large pharmaceutical
company you could spend your entire
career working on projects and never see
any one of those ever become a drug bone
to Market
because even if you get a drug to a
clinic 19 out of 20 of them will still
fail
Force failures also mean that patients
are being exposed to those tests uh
their hopes to be in brought up you know
they've been exposed to new medicines
which you don't know yet all the risks
exposed to Etc
so there's a huge sort of that's that
would still be the case with drugs that
you would potentially but if we also
think about how the personalized
medicine and precision medicine starts
to then sort of develop hopefully that
you also start to see sort of increased
response rates as well within trials in
time
so if you think about then I consider
sort of that to be a waste what we want
and what I'm really pleased at when I
say I was a drugstore science Discovery
scientist working as Alexander
is that within a short period of time
people in their careers now are seeing
drugs coming to the clinic moving
forward Etc you know and so that's an
important element as well it's how do we
ultimately
take all of the investment we've made
into education into science
and increase our ability to translate
the billions of pounds of investment we
make in basic research ultimately into
more new medicines for a patient the NHA
NIH did a study of sort of a translation
of basic research funded by the NIH into
new medicines
it can take sometimes you know 25
sometimes up to 40 years
before that sort of basic research when
it's first published actually becomes a
benefit to society in terms of new
medicine
ultimately what we want to do these
systems is how can we improve that the
odds of doing that and particularly all
of all of that I get I'm trying to I'm
trying to understand where the human
oversight is and where a human working
for your company is it what what is
their role now because they're not going
to be in their way of doing all these
tests today as it stands they are
running the projects they are making the
final decisions and everything they are
defined in the strategy you know it's
still very much a human driven process
with uh enhancements by new
computational techniques to try to
improve efficiencies
um what you're describing is some
potentially some future world which
potentially we we may end up in
but if we ever get to that point then I
think the other benefits to society
would already have been proven
themselves in that industry so I've um
so if we to get to that future World
um
government has to play a role in the
regulations so I mean what would be the
key considerations for government at the
moment if we're looking at the
regulation of AI and Drug development
for example sure
um we already have multiple layers of
Regulation uh which should be well
thoughtful for example whether it's the
safety regulations we have for medicines
whether it's the ethical regulations we
have for clinical trials whether it's
the privacy and confidentiality
regulations we have on data governance
all of these come into play so there's
nothing new is required if we're looking
at Medical Ai and medical research no I
think the risk is actually potentially
to over regulate a new industry before
we've actually worked out
actually how we actually are going to
apply I think that would cause some
nervousness for a lot of people that
you're talking about over regulation and
I think for for many people and there's
got to be public confidence in buy-in
for many people knowing that this had
some sort of oversight would give people
more confidence more
um assurance that the process was was
um
was going to be working in their best
interests I'm just wondering in order to
get to that place what should the
government you've said it shouldn't over
regulate but there must be some areas
that should be considered in areas where
people decisions are being made
um
automatically particularly if that would
affect
someone's outcomes then absolutely I
think they are there are potentially
Frameworks to understand about how those
decisions potentially being made other
being made automatically or are they
being made
um would that need to know how the AI
tool was open no it doesn't need to do I
think that's more of a case of oversight
if anything that's a way of a question
relies for example the exalt one trial I
described earlier
the excellent trial was recommended
which potential medicine a patient
should take it's not it's not actually
prescribing
actual prescription decision is still
made by The Physician looking at all the
data that's been generated and say this
is why look out of this data we believe
that potentially this medicine might
give a better response than this other
medicine
so it's fundamentally the Physicians
decision then to make that they are
responsible for the oversight the
systems we're talking about here
ultimately about how do we bring better
information
and recommendations based on that
information to the
responsible part of so to say
but it's still I think of in that
responsible parties you know interests
and they fundamentally must be
responsible as well for that decision as
it is today so it's about fundamentally
how do we provide new information so in
that sense I don't see AI as a
revolutionary Force I think actually it
fits within the exactly societal
Frameworks we have today
what it is is just a new approach
actually of how potentially we can be
more efficient in the use of data which
is now and that's what I mean to the
risk is actually not applying AI in many
cases because the risk is actually
business as usual which we know in many
cases is is inefficiency is cost not
just to Via the healthcare provider but
also to the patient as well so I think
we also need to look at the of um the
advantages as well that could come and
and understanding if we don't embrace
the possibility now of better decision
making better information that we awake
in a choice
to also lock ourselves into today's
framework
and if we if we're happy with the way
Healthcare Systems run today that's fine
I'm not okay so
changing tax slightly then
um you're obviously running a successful
company using AI in the research
what are the advantages of the UK
regulatory environment over other
jurisdictions and are there any
less advantageous aspects of the UK's
environment at the moment that's a
really good question I think the UK has
led the world actually in thinking about
I think some sensible Frameworks as I
said within data governance who within
safety of medicines within ethics Etc
I think he's well thought out uh
approaches actually
um the UA the the UK is also a leader in
how we think about the use of AI in
healthcare and the AI generally actually
we have been to coin for his pension
level weight I think in the early
development of this new technology
um we're not necessarily putting in as
much investment uh from both a private
sector and a public sector into where
this potentially could go but it is
interesting if you look at ourselves
benevolent AI in others actually it was
UK companies was actually some of the
first interviews whole area and I think
that reflects the environment that the
UK has had in terms of both the academic
backgrounds of producing investment into
AI but also the data backgrounds as well
as we prorated earlier UK has been
actually fantastic in creating large
data assets
all of this creates the right
environment right ecosystem for them
sort of Visa initiatives event to
flourish
what the UK needs to think about is we
have a very very strong life science
sector at the moment in terms of sort of
public investment and in terms of early
stage biotechs
it is maybe a certain pressures right
now in terms of sort of uh cost of drugs
pharmaceutical Market the UK is probably
less attractive to many sort of
international companies from that point
of view
so we don't necessarily
um plead to being an attractive Market
from that from a point of sort of
selling drugs we however can be an
attractive Market as a place to do
research and that I think is where the
UK strengths could be and that's why I
think having the right governance
framework uh is important to encourage
research encourage new ways of how
things could be done and also think
about how large data assets as we
mentioned earlier could be an important
part of n of attracting research to us I
think there's lots it's beyond risk
committee and it's beyond me to comment
about how we think about drug prices and
things like that I'm not going to talk
about that but so but I do think
actually we can control
um and we are on a very good position in
the supply side of things how we Supply
researchers for our education system how
we Supply the possibility of large data
assets uh for academics what funding
you've said is is
problematic or challenging that is not
necessarily A government funding
possibility that is much more of a
comments we're able to fund research
better I mean they'll be talking U.S
Germany these kind of places so we
listed on the NASDAQ in October 21. the
reason we listed on the NASDAQ and
rather than a London Stock Exchange is
because fundamentally
um
capital is much more fluid to attract in
the U.S we have an incredibly
International investor base from norfol
in Denmark to SoftBank in Japan to
Bailey Gifford and Scotland to have many
large U.S funds as well
and so what we found then is that the
stories that we can create in the UK
our attractive internationally actually
but what was hard actually is that we
built a company if I would say despite
being in the UK you know it wasn't a
support of UK investors had built
accentia it was a board of international
investors so the issue isn't necessarily
around government financing in UK or
government funding the bigger issue for
developing AIS and Industry is actually
that point between the startup and the
IPO and about how one attracts
International Capital into the UK Market
thank you my final question is about the
um again about regulations you talked
about the the requirement to have
decent regulations I can't quite
remember your exact in words but
do we have sufficient capacity to
develop proper regulations is there
expertise sufficient expertise in this
area that is a really good question yes
yes I'd be very briefly that's a really
good question because what you want to
you do need to understand the individual
domains AI being applied in each
different industry is going to require
actually a different framework
the way to approach it actually probably
more generally is to think about what
are the key societal issues one wants to
address issues of privacy issue
potentially around decision making and
agency and autonomy being taken away and
who is responsible for decisions
I think probably that's a better
position to start from because
individual regulation is going to be
down to each of the individual specific
industries that actually are sort of
being represented and probably
presenting evidence to you those are
very specific but I think actually there
are some very more General worries and I
think they actually are probably sitting
closer to the area of how we've fought
about data governance in terms of
privacy and confidentiality and actually
the governance Frameworks we put in
place for data thank you thanks very
much indeed um uh Steve metcal finally
and if we could keep things as concise
as possible we'll get on to the next
battle my best chairman
um following on from that just briefly
are there any International examples
that we should either look at to improve
our system or avoid to make sure that we
don't fall into the same
good question I think this field is
still so early but no one yet has made
uh you know two bad decisions or two
good decisions and that's the important
thing to remember we are still
innovating we're still evolving this
field is um only just now sort of
breaking open
we need to understand how we can apply
AI in lots of different kinds of
Industry so I think the the key
Advantage is this what's interesting
about the national strategy that was uh
proposed last year as well it really is
both fundamentally as well how we can
help many companies start to adopt AI I
fundamentally believe uh the companies
of a future will be AI first companies
and those which don't think like that
will actually be left behind Okay and
therefore you know if no one's quite got
it wrong or right completely yet do you
think that uh regulation there should be
sort of a harmonization a coordination
globally or is there a Competitive Edge
to be had from diversion for
diversification you you could argue for
both but considerings for example
um many systems obviously uh
transnational by definition the internet
is yeah then um if there are particular
issues you know around privacy around
agency uh particularly probably in more
of a social general public areas then
there is actually a strong argument for
thinking about what would be the
approach that one would take in a sort
of uh multinational level uh to approach
that because otherwise you know you can
use a website for manual world for
example however in terms of thinking
about specific industry applications
where you want to make industry more
more Dynamic and more efficient then I
think there is potentially a competitive
Advantage there and that's also
potentially connecting it to other
Investments and other strategies which a
national government can undertake such
as we talked about earlier about the
Investments the UK has made into large
data generation about the potential
assets we have with the NHS data and the
patient material there perfect thank you
and final question uh chair which is
around
um the government is about to publisher
of white paper and AI anything you'd
like to see in it this is your chance to
bid and have you as a sector been
consulted on that
um I don't think we've been consulted as
much as we should have been actually
um I feel like you know it's wonderful
to present for you today but we uh we
come as deep discussions as I believe we
could have I believe the UK has a
particular Advantage you can make in
terms of interaction of AI and
Healthcare and I would like to see
probably within our paper and approach
it but how we think about the elements
of data generation as a key part of it
ultimately AI is driven by quality data
and we need to think about our data
assets as a keypad on strategy I said
that was my last question can I just
clarify so
um
am I right and death was saying that
what you'll say as we move forward
very early in any process is to think
about how data if data is going to be
generated or gathered as part of any
process
how we might make that accessible to the
AI sector more widely so absolutely
build that in absolutely you need to
think a front around confidentiality
around ethics issues right from the
start as opposed to trying to do that
backwards with existing data perfect
John Butler wanted to do the
supplementary Christian if I had a
company and I used Quantum Computing
would I put your company out of business
no
why not
firstly we are developing the quantum
techniques alongside AI we believe the
future is the integration of AI with
physics-based techniques actually
um secondly
um what's interesting about sort of
creative AI is how one really thinks
about the interaction between the human
elements understanding human creativity
and how ultimately does one encode that
you know this is beyond just a simple
algorithm it's actually about a whole
ecosystem of algorithms and how they
interact you know the mission accent
here is to encode an automated Discovery
and that means ultimately understanding
the human creative element of it as well
thank you thank you John
um my many interesting things you said
Professor Hawkins so one was that um
people in the pharmaceutical industry
could the research like go through their
whole career without having a drug that
actually works with patients uh and we
have heard evidence we've had evidence
this inquiry that uh 86 percent of drug
development programs between 2000 2015
were unsuccessful
um you had a long career with Pfizer did
you find that in terms of attracting
people to make careers in
Pharmaceuticals that was becoming a
problem people were literally committing
their life to something that didn't come
up with anything beneficial what's
fascinating is that the people I know
who work in the biotech Farm industry
and the life science academic world as
well really are committed to this space
you know many of us could probably earn
higher salaries elsewhere Etc it's
really driven by a mission actually
people are really dedicated to want to
see their skills their knowledge science
they do really apply to creating new
medicines I think it's very much a sort
of mission-driven sort of vocation
actually but outside that did you
experience that people were being put
off from going into a sector once it
entered a phase of much less certain
success in terms of the clinical well
people was potentially being put off by
the fact that this lack of success as
you call it the economic implications as
you might remember did lead to a very
significant number of job losses in the
UK in the pharmaceutical industry we had
many many large research sites closed
down and many other companies sort of
moved back to the US so the impact has
been actually a reduction in the
pharmaceutical industry in the UK over
the past 20 years this is fundamentally
what I'd like to think so if AI is
successful in drug Discovery it could
it's economic impacts can be
transformational I found fundamentally
believe this is the next phase where
pharmaceutical industry actually thank
you very much indeed espresso because
you've been very generous of your time
and we've learned a lot of very useful
information from that can I ask our next
panel of witnesses to join us here at
the table as they take their seats I
will introduce them and they are
Professor delmiro Fernandez Reyes uh
Professor Fernandez Reyes is Professor
of biomedical Computing at University
College London and is also adjunct
professor in Pediatrics College of
Medicine of the University of ibadan in
Nigeria
and the professor is also a medical
doctor and has pioneered the use of
machine learning approaches to further
understanding childhood malaria amongst
other things and welcome alongside him
professor Michaela Van Der shaar who is
Professor of machine learning and
artificial intelligence and medicine and
director of the Cambridge Center for AIA
medicine and is a professional
University
and Professor Van Der Shaw's main
research areas of the application of AI
and machine learning to medical and
Healthcare challenges obviously very
relevant to our inquiry today which is
also a true faculty fellow at the Turing
Institute many affiliations thank you
very much indeed for coming and giving
evidence today perhaps I could start off
with Professor vandershaw you were a
member I think of the
the the topple review that was
commissioned in 2017 by our colleague
Jeremy Hunt in
Italy then as the Secretary of State for
Health and Social care
published a report in 2019 and it was
looking at Technologies in health and
Medicine there was a panel looking from
2017 into the impact of AI and you
co-chaired that panel I think could you
personally reflect on what youth what
you thought then and how things have
been since then because as we know
people reported in 2019 but you know
three little bit years is a long time in
the development of AI thank you very
much indeed I have co-chaired that so
just for context the topple review had
three different strands one was genomics
one was digital medicine and the one
that I co-chaired was indeed related to
AI
and I would say that the pandemic
somewhat indirectly helped in the
digital medicine aspect of the panel
because all the clinicians were using
Technologies to really serve their
patients at a much faster Pace than
anticipated
you know I I would say some progress has
been made so the health education
England has instantiated last year 10
fellowships for clinicians that are
part-time learning and
developing Technologies in AI
I would say that uh and 10 new
clinicians will be induct will be
enrolled in this program this year I
would say 20 clinicians so far is
relatively a modest number of course the
pandemic in this case has hurt what I
really wish to see why would I what I
would have hoped to see is much more
involvement with the eye in the clinical
space and again I personally do not want
to turn clinicians into machine learners
but I really would have hoped that they
would understand these Technologies a
lot better not only to adopt them but to
shape them so what I really was very
passionate in that particular report was
for the clinicians not only to be at the
receiving end of this Technologies but
to be much more involved in developing
these Technologies and providing the
right
um way of thinking about what we really
need
thank you and was it your thoughts is it
your thoughts that AI would go from
being a narrow and rather specialized
field
to being
mainstream was the word that was used in
the past it's spread across the sector
or would you expect a an expertise to be
retained within Specialists but they
would become more influential as a as an
expert group so first I see AI purely as
a tool not only in medicine but in
transportation in finance in businesses
in many domains and I myself have worked
in many areas prior to falling in love
to with area of medicine so I think this
technology is really something that can
Empower many domains but I do think that
currently too much is pushed by people
like me in machine learning imposing
these Technologies on others rather than
educate them about this and allowing
them to develop this technology so I see
this more or less as a tool that for
instance in this case clinicians could
shape such that they develop tools that
are useful for them and in that regard
it is important that they are aware
about both the possibilities as well as
the dangers of the technology such that
the right tools are built
rather than pushed onto indeed finally
for me before I turn to Christian
Wakefield
um uh in the the your strand of the the
top or uh review in reporting in 2019 it
said that AI will transform
patient-generated data into clinically
useful information and Empower patients
to manage their own health or seek
appropriate health support and you said
the patient benefits should be the
driving force behind AI with new
products co-developed with patients from
design to implementation is that still
your view and would you make a comment
on how it's happened in practice since
you wrote those words thank you very
much it is very much still my view as a
matter of fact while I do think that
drug drug Discovery is a very important
aspect of our Healthcare I think even
better is if we are never getting sick
if we can prevent disease if we can
identify disease early such that maybe
we don't need to be treated or we need
to be treated minimally
so I think as a potential patient
um I still that this is very important I
think it should be at the Forefront of
any technology in Ai and I think in my
opinion too much is focused on
um treating disease rather than using AI
to prevent disease to make sure that we
identify early disease and if a patient
discover develops a particular disease
gets at the right time the right
intervention in the right location and
according to their wishes thank you very
much indeed just before I Turn to You to
Christian um I mentioned the professor
Fernandez Reyes was was nodding during
what you said there perhaps you might
just add a comment yeah I certainly
agree yeah focused towards preventative
medicine is a seriously important okay
because that is certainly produces costs
significantly significantly across the
acroset public health and preventative
medicine
um what we're saying about the training
of magnesians into the domain uh before
which is very important which has been
happening over 2020 years of MRC has
been focusing on the in fact I am a
product of that because I'm not trying
computer scientists too I specialize in
machine learning so I'm not just a medic
so uh in that in the area so there is a
two-way Avenue in that way so it's not
only is we need to train clinicians into
understandable as well the machine
learning is the machine people who
technology can to into what is the
domain a specific characteristics very
good thank you very much it's Christian
Whitefish
um thank you chair to uh Professor van
obviously you suggested two distinct uh
AI categories obviously the petri dish
and reality-centric
um obviously it's looking at both of
them it would appear that the
reality-centric is more suited to
medical research could you explain why
but also could you think of any
circumstances while in the petri dish
approach would be more appropriate so
for people tuning in that may be
unfamiliar with those terms just to
explain them yeah thank you very much so
as a matter of fact it's relatively
recently that I coined to these two
terms partially because of concern with
the way in which the machine learning
and the Eye Community to which I part 10
is going
so I see a reality-centric guy is AI
that can operate effectively accountably
and reliably in the real world and which
focuses on problems which are
human-centric and messy I like to end a
previous member of your panel refer to
humans being imperfect and messy so it
is very much focused on that and this is
I would say the core of AI for
healthcare AI for Education AI for
business and that was as opposed to What
I Call Petri disha which is very much
focused on developing AI technology for
playing games
or for that matter even by for solving
technological problems scientifical
problems that are very well defined such
as for instance protein folding this is
wonderful and I think it needs to
continue but
um really the world is not a game a
board of Chess or even of go because the
reality is in the settings that we
operate under complete information
um everything is known the rules of the
games are very well predefined and the
reality of the world if it takes we take
something like the NHS it is a complex
messy
data I would say iPhone the environment
is changing according to rules we can
not not really predict
um events such pandemics happen
um data is not the more the better so I
can play billions of games of go and
learn the game I cannot reorganize the
NHS billions of times
so
um I've written this piece to
concentrate the minds of my community
the artificial intelligence Community
but I would say more generally the world
to not only focus on this let's say
hyped areas of solving games but also to
focus on really the solving problems
that are there in the real world such as
problems that NHS encounters due to for
instance limited resources or
complexities such as this pandemic it's
a petri dish just to be clear that it's
a kind of protected artificial
environment as opposed to the real and
messy world and also very well defined
and very clear so for instance defining
um the determining proteins for instance
and protein folding it's a very clear
complex important but very well defined
problem while if it is for me to develop
AI to improve the performance of the NHS
and to empower clinicians in the NHS
that's a much clearly defined less
clearly defined problem but I would say
even more important and even more
exciting and I would like my community
to focus much more on these real world
problems and not just focus on very
Niche areas
Professor Fernandez Reyes was very key
to come in on that let me focused days
because like this comments colleagues
here so let's focus on the word
uncertainty okay uncertainty is actually
very linked to governance because
want to go burn is because you want to
create trust and trustworthiness of
material of a technical or one approach
one of the things that the the machine
learning and the artificial intelligence
Academia and other researchers in
Industry have tackle at least precisely
that with probabilistic approaches which
precisely they are very successful of
tackling uncertainty of a system despite
they have done it because of games and
we're using the famous alphago of Google
andovers the important part of that is
that with that Frameworks we can tackle
precisely uncertainty so so that feel is
important because of that now we need to
extrapolate that and to put into a
governance framework those
characteristics of these systems in fact
it's not trivial so the the the the the
the the things we do with protein faulty
is actually very complex system
essentially very uncertain okay and
those those I will not call that pretty
rich which so it actually they are
solved not sold but they're actually
giving a tool which can augment humans
to tackle uncertainty now we need to
have cohere number it for our
prosperity in healthcare and all that
today is allow me to intervene in just
one second to say that this is not just
about uncertainty I'm not saying that
these problems are not difficult to
solve you have a large State space that
you need to solve and you solve protein
folding or you're playing go what I'm
saying here is that it's not about just
uncertainty it's about modeling very
complex messy systems that have humans
in them and simple games of go or even
complex problems like plotline folding
do not capture the complexity of the
real world like we have in
transportation systems and damages it is
to this point that I made this point of
difference
I wonder if I can ask both the two just
to kind of raise your voices a little
although you've got microphones in front
of you that's for broadcasting rather
than in the room
so it's uh it's a it's a long way
between uh between uh units but
Christian thank you Joe um also to
prevent uh Professor solve CV Center
aims to identify regulation safety
privacy and ethical standards within the
AI and machine learning
how's the progress of this so far and
why is it so important
I think
extremely important to make sure
especially for AI in healthcare AI for
criminal justice AI for Education that
we built very
um
careful transparent and
ethical Ai and in that regard the
committee discussed some very important
questions
earlier because we cannot build high
quality eye unless we have high quality
data and unfortunately high quality data
requires dealing with a lot of biases
a lot of noise a lot of errors and again
it is not just having a lot of data we
need to have the right data because
otherwise all sorts of issues and biases
are going to be actually propagated
I think in my opinion not enough energy
is spent on really developing technology
inclusively AI technology to improve the
quality the representation and the
biases in the data so that is I think
something that is a Forefront of my
research but I wish more people would
worry about not only building analytics
but making sure that the data on which
they build this analytics indeed is of
the right quality
at the level of
algorithms I think it is again very very
important to make sure not only that
these algorithms are working well at the
population level but also are working
well in minority groups and that we
really audit these algorithms for not
only Global performance but also
individual performance
it's almost like you're saying the data
is messy to Professor Finance also
considering your background both as a
biomedical scientist and a medical
doctor can you explain the benefits of
AI to both fields of work of course so
I'm a computer scientist too so um so
the medicine many okay so in terms of
what we built we talking before to help
us most of these techniques which are
diverse in their own right okay there is
not just a single AI thing which being
evolved over 30 years with three waves
of it at the current moment in the last
decade it has helped us to understand
for example complexity of phenomena
especially in biological systems in my
case I focus now on understanding the
pathology of malaria in children why
some children go to develop severe
anemia that needs transmission that's a
very complex disease it has many factors
from the population to the child
genetics and other components of the
actual infectious ages so in a way for
some part of this technique so this
paradigms are allowed us to take the
data as our previous evidence speaker
take very complex data into ways we can
actually make sense find patterns in the
data so these patterns might be
important once we got patterns we can
reverse back and it's a very difficult
phenomena in the sense that you go from
the to a reductionist path you form
hypothesis just I just give you an idea
so when we talk about omics we wore in
three dimensions more what we see you
start adding variables stuff becomes
like a cube of many points and we cannot
imagine it's very complex so this has
been very useful these techniques over
the top the philosophies that has to
form find identified patterns and then
you can go back to the lab find patterns
and find this famous called biomarkers
how can I simplify this in a biomarket
and allows us to
in the stratified risk and for example
what the previous speaker was saying
it's precisely how we stratify patients
in a will benefit for this drug or the
risk so that is the base one other part
of it the second part is how do I do
with that what do I do with it diagnosis
is a very complex matter a human a medic
trends for 10 years meaning and is a
very it's basically a complex machine
associating benefits but It suffers from
cognitive tires cognitive loads errors
and biases is impossible you know not to
have advice so this thing is a currently
augmented in terms of the agnosis I mean
the work of a clinician or a work of a
clinical charity not necessarily because
it's not only the clinician security and
the augmentation that provides actually
can increase uh speed up on referrals or
as we were saying preventing that this
is going worse Etc so this can be
another area in which is clear
advantages we can put into it as well of
course at all they are of the areas that
can't translate into a treatment
obviously so yeah in my case we look for
explaining the disease finding
biomarkers and actually as well using
that as the agnosis preventative also
what what can I fantasy individual
service okay of course that depends all
which is always depend on context
dependent of the disease a biomedical
the mind will be like that so it's not
the same this conversation we have too
much is focusing so much on diseases
which are characteristic of long living
individuals in a population cancer
neurogenitive neurodegenerative
really there is pay attention for
example infectious disease it's
completely different
approach okay so infectious things you
need to treat quickly otherwise you know
you'll see the fat quick
and and coming all that the use of that
is how you go burn this space okay
because that is what we in a way doing
here so it is true I can't develop all
those things how can I put this system
stuff the person who is going to benefit
the most of that which is the clinician
trust that is going to take a clinical
decision that is not going to be legally
affecting that person and the patient
which is going to be atrocity
thank you
um I think that actually answers the
next question as well thank you very
much lead well that's a great question I
think Catherine wants to come in on that
Joseph Lee I want to make sure I
understand what you're saying you're
talking about complexity in systems and
in human in in human and biological
systems that's effectively a bell curve
distribution and what you're what if I
understand you correctly what you're
saying is you need data that's
representative of the entirety of the
bell curve so I don't know proteins on
the outside of the code of the
plasmodium falseparim or MHC complexes
within the individual child that's
getting malaria or something like that
are you
the fruit to be
a clinicians confident that the overlay
of all of those different distributions
of bell curves are within the data to
allow the AI to not spit you know
rubbish out no not necessarily not
necessarily because I also says context
that bend uh it's context dependent okay
again it's not it's not necessarily belt
check because you're talking about the
distribution of the individuals that
generate the states the data can be
multi multi-dimensional it can be
millions of data points yeah and you can
choose a characteristics of data point
MLB bed shape or this is not that's why
that's what this AI techniques are very
very good to do complex models to solve
discriminatory patterns however it's
very difficult to explain precisely
because it's not just as simple as a as
a gaussian shape but coming back to to
diasa today it's not the same of AI
system I feel for example for malaria
detecting malaria in let's say Nevada
and when we have
High prevalence of the disease it's very
frequent it's very common than one for a
AI system that we put in Heathrow to
detect which Travelers have malaria okay
it's a completely different part so you
can be a technician which you can
measure that but it is true that if you
for example the image array has to start
looking at this in 20 in 2022 and one of
the the the the high level topics they
say is there is no framework in which
yeah that's what I'm kind of get at so
if from our perspective we're trying to
make sure that this stuff is understood
that it's not producing stuff that's
potentially of a lack of benefit and and
I'm kind of interested in how you're
saying there's got lots of potential but
the data is important but you know I
mean protein folding could down to be
like Quantum effects you know how on
Earth do you put that into it yeah as
well yeah okay thank you I'm conscious
I'm stealing errands right well we're
going to come back to you Catherine but
um to Aaron then come
great question
I wanted to you've just talked about
opportunities I wanted to ask you both
about the risks I think Professor Amanda
Charles talked about them a little bit
already but from your perspective
Professor Fernandez Reyes what are the
biggest risks of using AI in medical
research so the I think the biggest risk
we have is first we don't know what we
don't know except in the implementation
okay and of course the the risk we have
discussed I think through the session
you know this resource not being
transparent the ways of giving
explanation that may work but we don't
know how to do it safety in the domain
is critical so we say well are we
creating problems aggregating systems
which are not safe or therefore robust
okay that's one of the key issues of the
monarchy of research in biomedical
medical research and AI systems which
are deep deep representations I don't
know you that what protein folded all
this I don't need models of the machine
learning those those models actually are
very susceptible of small changes and
for example completely different outcome
for example and and that is one of the
risks we need to analyze that points
boils down to as as the medicine
regulatory agency was saying that we
need to create data sets and tools in
which I can the guidelines and how do I
test this system to be safe how to test
the system it's not trivial that
requires Resurgence its own right that
drives an interdisciplinary team escaped
stakeholders which could include you
know data scientists mathematicians and
other people including the technicians
and Regulatory agency to create that
toolbox so I think I think you could see
it clearly I was happy when I read the
2020 October 2020 report the meteorite
has three work packages
on on precisely AI as a medical device
yes okay that is the beginning of the
conversation I think
it needs to they need to be resources on
that because the safety framework of
medical about medicine is there okay now
we need to put this AI as a medical
device or a medical a framework on top
of that and that's I think precisely
where where decisions of lack of safety
transparency interpretability
representation and inclusion as mihail
has been saying before are those issues
that need to have a framework in which
how do we enforce known Force how do I
do compliance to this so if I come with
a new system sure I'll come to a second
are these new risks or are they just
evolutions of the risks that are already
there have always been there in medical
research the safety is always a phrase
yes there's also inclusion yeah there's
been always there because I give you a
very simple example
you know children when they develop we
measure them and and we develop and
putting in a core yes this course I
developed in the North in for mostly
people predominantly living and off and
myself
over the years
create one from south of southern Africa
I just recently out because this doesn't
exists and this is just a table okay and
a piece of paper I'm not talking about
AR so these problems exists this problem
of sampling populations inclusions is
down because of course this is larger
scale now we go internet we go
globalization this thing is here is of
the bottle in a way so it is the
problems are there but they are actually
financially vegan thank you and I'm the
president thank you so very much I'm
briefly reiterating explainability
transparency bias trustworthiness are
all very very important and I myself
work a lot on them but I think something
that's not enough said is this medicine
and Healthcare are a human-centric
subject right and I think one of the
dangers is that if we do not think
carefully and we do not regulate
carefully technology we will build
methods which are considering the
patient as a square
we will make the wrong abstractions
about what patients need uh the
complexity of the patients and the
complexity of the healthcare so that's
the reason again I'm going back to this
reality-centric agenda because I really
want to see the human the patient the
human declination at the Forefront of
that and one of the dangers I think of
building AI that aims to be artificial
general intelligence is that we forget
about humans I like very much recommend
that was made earlier that this needs to
be humans need to be at the Forefront of
this and it is them and their needs as a
population and as individuals and I'm
concerned to some extent about the lack
of emphasis on the human-centric aspects
of this technology so how should we as
policy makers address that
I think that what
profits first or
um
drugs and Innovation first we really
need to understand so so for instance
let me a little bit backtrack there is a
lot of discussion about cutting-edge
Technologies for drug discoveries and I
think that they are very important but I
think machine learning can play an even
bigger role to do the Dirty Work
to be able to improve Logistics in the
NHS to be able to identify so in the
pandemic my group which was just a
professor and two students we joined
forces with NHS digital to predict to
use the first machine learning tools
that I think have been used in the
entire UK to predict how many bets do we
need how many ventilators we need who
needs them so we talk very often about
this very lofty eye and we are going to
know everything about the human which I
think is wonderful but I think we can
use
AI for Logistics to solve problems of
what type of resources we need when to
predict one a particular patient should
return we talk again about drugs and
giving people drugs but the reality is
that at times a patient may be at very
high risk and currently I is very much
used of one size it's all and we can
identify which patients should come to
be screened how often
um if they have disease when should they
come back
uh how often should they come back
um what are their competing risks
associated with it these are complex
messy issues that I think are very
important to be considered and we forget
about them so in terms of improving the
health of the nation you would say we
should focus much more on systems and
diagnosis yeah and Lord the logistics
part of it and put some of our Amazon's
AI into the NHS
um but with the realization that we are
not taking
profit uh the focus is really the
Healthcare of the population and using
this technology as empowerment rather
than uh creating incentives and markets
that may not be there do you want to
further comment Professor so uh I agree
agree on most what we had to say is true
and but coming back to to you say
um if you but we were talking about the
topple report before but there was a
subsequent report
nhsx in which actually
put all this Ai and governance in there
so I think it's worth revisiting as well
because the top report didn't went into
into governance and and I was focusing
most on the AI and Robotics
um and but coming back to the agnesis
diagnosis problems and outcomes and
prevention as we saw before okay of
course treatment which is the drug
Discovery part is important axis okay
right and and and
exactly so what we're trying to say is
that this is a whole
from from the individual the individual
is born in a society to its completion
of the life cycle and Society is a
complex interaction of all these factors
and of course I can I ask a question to
the panel is that possible actually do
you know do you know how many assistants
are currently implemented in the NHS AIS
as a device not many but they know a lot
okay so just recently
2022 nice of evaluated the the use of AI
systems for diabetic retinopathy okay
which is AI systems are very good at
looking at images so the biggest changes
the biggest the low hanging fruit at the
moment is Medical Imaging okay uh and it
is different variety so diabetic
retinopathy it is a
supposing fruit that we could say uh
nice as a report on that in 2022 and the
other important one which is coming out
soon is the city for a suspected stroke
analysis automatic analysis of CTS kinds
of individuals suspects tremendous
potential for for a societal chanting
our society so those systems are already
being evaluated by nice together of
course with with the regulatory agency
but qualifying what we found is that the
framework and Regulatory agency despite
we already say in 2016 and now it needs
to be regulation but it needs to be
agile okay so and and that comes back to
to what the previous person was talking
about
you must assist but it's how you be the
complexities how you'll be a regulator
ideal enough to Don't Stop innovation
what you need to put is I will say okay
is to put resources and the knowledge in
institutions like the regulatory engines
in which we have been UK regulatory is
actually quite mature and good and put
this interdisciplinary is expertise I'll
give you an example
so the person before I spoke about
medicines and trials but he hasn't felt
the most important problem they have
clinical trial methodology is not
developed to understand more than 10
variables at a time okay where we go
with AI things is is crazy right I
understand but
yeah I've got a suggestion I want to
test for you
so basically
and the clinical trial units in the MRC
invested heavily on this in the clinical
units now are matured enough to bring
the AI component which is what we call
adaptive trials okay advice which are
not only the classical way but they are
adaptive and there are two new branches
of doing trials which is what is called
umbrella trials and the basket trials
and that comes to the question
personalized medicine n equals one so
those trials are the way to do it but
that means if we're going to capitalize
from the whole thing because a device
needs to a trial everything even even a
logistic system will need to have an
implementation trust so we need to
facilitate the knowledge inside the
Regulatory and the stakeholders towards
allow agile regulation thank you so just
uh just for example just on that point
so we need to have a recognition in the
the regulation of clinical trials of
this these new opportunities are there
other jurisdictions in the world that
you're aware of where they're already
doing this for clinical devices so at
the U.S so remember that in terms of
what the person was speaking before it
was U.S is very big in cancer research
okay yes do you guys have a similar
approach towards light touch okay in
this area in AI in fact they have
already approved many AI as a medical
devices
Etc we have a light Dodge the European
Union has a more strict uh more or less
Innovative so if it's more Hands-On
regulation and my my my concept I agree
with that regulation on Moses sitting
all the areas that that Michaela was
talking no transparency Etc but is to
bring the agility to it and the only way
we do that is to train the regulator
so need to put the strip
interdisciplinarity into the regulation
and the pandemic has shown so that very
clearly thank you um Professor Spanish
I'd like to in to say again two things
so as one of the researchers in the UK
and I would dare say internationally
that has done the most research on
machine learning for clinical trials and
changing clinical trials
for a very long time and collaborate
with both people in the United States
where I was a professor for many years
as well as Europe I think again this
looking at clinical tiles and looking at
the many steps of clinical trials and
understanding the complexity of it again
is a complex system problem because it's
about which patients you recruit do you
recruit the right patients or do you
select only some minority groups that
you are testing and then when the drugs
end up being
um on the market only certain patients
May most benefit
so again looking at all looking at those
looking at those responses not only
about drugs and components and precision
medicine but it is also about the right
dose that is given to a particular
patient currently also patients are
included in clinical trials that do not
have comorbidities and the reality is
most famous patients that will get this
drug will have comorbidities and will be
elderly also another very important
aspect is after a drug is approved what
happens to this drug afterwards is this
drug going to have long-term side
effects this is going to be creating
additional comorbidities so it is really
not only it's about both regulating and
improving clinical trials but also is
about the long-term effects and how do
does particular drug going to be
valuable in a particular ecosystem for
instance the NHS which is really quite
different as the UK us or European
market so again this emphasis on the
complexity of the end-to-end systems
that I think are very important but I
really would like to jump also on the
previous discussion so we hear a lot
about how AI is miraculous in radiology
and imaging and I myself have worked in
this era for many many years but I think
that is an even better opportunity and I
want to re-emphasize that which is using
AI to solve logistic problems to predict
what we need when we need to be able to
help with really the infrastructural
aspects of this well that's very clearly
from your items it's very useful can I
turn to Catherine otherwise we're going
to run out of time but uh we may so I I
just want to make sure that it's I'm
going to translate what is very
sophisticated it's simple just to make
sure so you're saying that at the moment
clinical trials in the AI cannot have a
load of blokes having HRT tested on them
and if those blokes have also got
diabetes then the AI is going to come
out with an answer but it's going to be
absolute nonsense so she's nodding
you're not let's just I just want to try
and simplify it for normal human beings
roughly
right okay
um
so yeah yeah yeah the thing is is you
guys get it I'm trying to simplify it
just to give it a for instance that will
never happen but Professor Vander sharp
your reality-centric model is
effectively now sitting into two subsets
as we hear your evidence there's almost
a novel Discovery piece and then there's
an infrastructure Logistics and planning
piece now the novel Discovery as well as
the medical imaging is really getting
lots of attention at the moment but and
I think it's impressively but a
regulator's got to understand what's
coming up given all of these
complexities we're diving into so I'm
going to say three things and I want you
to just tell me whether they're nonsense
I will
you need known results known set data
sets to go through an AI because if you
know the answer and the AI isn't coming
out with the answer that's known then
there's a problem you need to test those
knowns going through and then most AIS
in novel Discovery need to be giving
probabilistic scores on results and
range estimates to allow for the
uncertainty in the data set if a
regulator did that would it be a good
place to start
I would say this is a good place to
start but I do think that more is needed
because you really need to look again at
sub populations and you need to make
sure that this is true not only the
population level but also the support
yeah that would be in the known results
see that's the known results list right
okay
um do you want to go into the future uh
yes but very briefly right okay and
we've talked a lot about the future and
about
um we just let's just speculate do you
think it's possible for a drug to be
discovered entirely by Ai and if it is
how long how far away in the future is
it uh professor vanisher again my
emphasis is not so much on just
discovering drugs is making sure that
the right drug is given at the right
time to the right patient with the right
dose and I think again it's too much
focus on just the discovery there are
many other complexity to make a drug
effective in a population thank you
Professor
assuming that drug Discovery means
effective I will agree with this is
not they die for doing that
2006.i the AI can say have a look at
this but the complexity to make sure
it's safe in humans is not within an AI
perfect right and I've got okay I'll
stop now
um so I want to I think I'm I'm quite
interested in chasing through this
this diagnosis this idea that provided
you tested the AI to be you know with a
known so I am a 47 year old middle-aged
woman who's likely having reduced
estrogen or whatever you know yeah and
you you know that I'm probably in that
bucket and you put me through the II and
out pops out talk to her about HRT so
can you just give us an idea of this
kind of screening and diagnosis advances
because I don't think that AI exists at
the moment thank you very much for that
so we have done research in numerous
diseases and across everything from
cancer a variety of cancers to cystic
fibrosis to alzheimer's to
cardiovascular disease to Endocrinology
to many others and the reality is that
the technology exists today it's a lot
better than the statistical technologies
that are currently used in the Q risk
scores that are used in the UK we have
validated this in more than a million
patients the trouble with this is that
it is not the fleshy AI that gets
Primetime news but the reality is that
the technology is in place and I really
wish that I was not an academic I was
somebody that could translate it to the
NHS but we have worked closely together
with NHS digital to build some of these
Technologies but I think that they could
be transformative because currently when
you go to the clinician number one you
are tested for maybe one or two risks
but the reality is that a push of a
button you could be tested for many
years as you're saying a standard run of
blood screens with a genetic set of
coding and some basic knowledge about an
individuality it could spit out I've had
word with them about this definitely and
what is very no I disagree on this is
what is very interesting here is we
think the more data the better we need
genomics we need this no the reality is
that some of these technologies will
enable us to tell what's the minimum
amount of information we need to know
about this particular patient so we
always think wrongly about AI partially
because of wrong narrative we think we
need big data sets we need genomics we
need expensive tests no we do not for
many diseases we need actually
relatively few amount of information
about the patient to make a relatively
good provided it was a probabilistic 80
chance maybe I have a bit of an actor
exactly and maybe I can increase the
risk the the the certainty if I do a
particular additional blood test yeah or
maybe I would need to and another
important thing is it's not only one
moment in time you are a history so as
you are evolving through your life you
may end up having I don't know an
increase in a particular biomarker you
may lose weight you may increase weight
you may have other diseases being
diagnosed what AI is good at is looking
at these trajectories and trajectories
of disease to predict risk and competing
let me just simplify that again and I'll
bring Professor Fernandez Rose so for
example the classic folklore would have
the somebody with cancer will lose
weight beforehand even if they're not
presented to a doctor so what you're
saying in a routine medical checkup if
there's a if there is a significant drop
from a previously stable way that might
be enough of a trigger to go for a very
simple cancer blood screen is that kind
of what you mean yes this is what kind
of art I mean so it is looking at it and
this is again where AI can be very
helpful because as a clinician I may not
remember very well and I'm not able to
integrate across time
so as I said we don't choose the patient
what the patient comes in so that
example of I have the eye system is like
the good thing about the human Trend
over 10 years is like in IR in IR room I
don't choose who comes to me I have to
be prepared to whatever drugs of course
there are different things that come to
you because the populations are
different but I think this seems like
what we describe it is medicine medicine
knows this you know that what you think
of all over the hundreds of years
medicine evolved that is what the medic
does okay put people in a risk and
clinicians all clinicians over the time
they're very good at saying No this is
developing the race
so what is very difficult is to
translate that into a expert system or
AI system so the good Olive in the
current text of AI is in a way to
summarize it if you have an overworked
GP which have to be 60 people in 5
minutes you can provide a reasonably
good enough summary of where that person
is is gonna come in I need to look in
five minutes and maybe do a test and
change the life that is what yes but
what may I always translated that
because that clinician is overloaded
yeah very finally can I just say um the
bed and pandemic modeling must have been
very bleeding edge and it's very
important at the time so thank you for
that work thank you chair thank you very
much
um fascinating discussion just now and
I was very much on board with everything
that you were saying in regards to
preventative medicine using AI for that
and position medicine and you know
personalized care which I think we are
moving more towards personalized care
and how AI could help with that and then
during your discussion I thought
um
the risks in regards to insurance
companies for instance
uh identifying person using this
technology to say oh this person's more
likely to develop diabetes so therefore
their insurance premium is going to go
up
how do we prevent that abuse that is
fantastic because I lived in United
States for 18 years and I was my mother
and my grandmother died young of breast
cancer and I was terrified to do a
screening test for braca because I was
afraid that if I would end up having it
I would end up not getting treatment
luckily I do not have braca but the
reality is that I think that here is
where regulation is very very important
because we do not want people not to do
tests that may be relevant and identify
this is early because both because of
the cost to the society and cost to the
individual this is very important so
this is where I'm very I feel very
pleased and fortunate to be within the
UK system that would not allow this
differentiation and this is very much
the case in some cases in United States
fortunately with Obamacare this is not
really a problem anymore even in the UK
in the US but I think that this is is we
want to not prevent people from having
insurance and high quality Healthcare we
want to encourage them to discover this
is really high risk early and help them
Ian
um really personalizing their care given
this this risks and we need to realize
the risk is not all genetic and at times
certain risks are modifiable
so I mean that's going to take some
really uh
stringent regulations and framework to
ensure that there's not that abuse and
ethics will come into this so strongly I
really hope at a great
and I think that this is very very in as
a society to realize that we shouldn't
prevent certain people who it's not
their choice to to have a particular
mutation or be a particular risk and we
need to really be able to serve these
populations as well but I think that
here regulation is very important
and can you
um
can you explain what does palantir do do
you know much about the organization
patent here what do they do what do you
feel about the role that they're
currently playing in our NHS system can
you talk about that at all yeah so I
would like to say I'm quite concerned
about that
um I really would like to see much more
Focus not only on certain applications
and certain Niche applications but
rather much more
um this area being open to many more
companies
allow for better regulation and also I
would say from what I saw early on in
the pandemic was too much focused on
some areas rather than other areas of AI
and again I think that we need to think
about utilitarian AI that can really has
the individual at the Forefront and the
NHS system at the Forefront so I really
would have liked to see more diversities
of companies available in this space not
only a few players and also much more
transparent use of why certain
commissions are given to certain
companies and make sure that this is
really across the board making sure that
that the right technology is in place
and at times I'm underwhelmed as a
machine learning researcher by seeing
what this company is produce in terms of
AI I think is very limited and not very
Cutting Edge
thank you doctor I I agree with me on
those comments so that that regulation
and open competition is actually even
good for the industry but it comes down
a lot of the black it's like a black box
of the black box so our assistant it's
in their own right they are black boxes
and we have a problem and regulation
that and now you put that in that
setting as you say you put the Black Box
on the top of the block most difficult
and in terms of what you were talking
about insurance before it's already
happening I fly with the use of of these
devices their insurance that provide a
cheaper insurance payments if you do
activity okay I increase with Los
activity uh it's interesting it's kind
of incentivation approach but it can
have a different precautions as well
just imagine that person should suppose
a person have a problem with uh with uh
this is cannot be active the premiums
are going to be more expensive why so so
there needs to be there needs to be
interesting regulation on the Insurance
system but that is a big big task yeah
big skill does yeah thank you
thing so I'm also a very big of course
I'm an academic but I'm a big believer
in open source software and I think
rather than having one company palantir
or another company I think what would be
wonderful for the government is to
really Embrace this type of Open Source
platforms where industry as well as
academics are providing this type of
Technology it can be inspected by anyone
there is an equal barrier to entry for
people and as a community we can build
tools that are generally useful I think
too little is done on open source my own
lab which is relatively small lab tries
to put as much as we can in open source
software that's sufficiently reliable
and we really hope that people take this
Technologies and build useful platforms
for the NHS yes I totally agree thank
you and my last question chair is
um
so you mentioned which is like very dear
to my heart
AI reducing profits and centering on
people uh
now
do you think do you worry that
there will be large organizations and
company that makes a lot of profit
from
medicines and tablets do you think they
will try and find a way to sabotage
this kind of thinking yes I worry a lot
as a person I worry a lot so that's why
I kept on saying we shouldn't Focus only
on drug and Drug Discovery and we
shouldn't Focus only on the industry we
should really focus on the individual as
well as the NHS because I think what we
want is to make sure that we improve the
Healthcare of the population we give
minimum amount of interventions we give
them when it's needed and
um I am afraid at times that the data we
collect is also biased and is again not
only the data at one point it's also the
data over time as interventions are made
because the more intervening a biased
and not okay way the more data will show
this is the right way to go because we
do not have counter factors for what
would have happened otherwise so yes I'd
worry about that I think a lot more
research and careful thinking needs to
take place there we took some evidence
as somebody who said oh if we think
about the bias we'll never get anything
done
I'm afraid that if we don't think about
the bias you'll get a lot of very bad
things done as clearly the research has
thrown I think this is an
underappreciated area and I think a lot
more research and thinking is to come
into it and it's non-trivial because
there is not only bias at the collection
point it's biased in interventions
because certain people get certain types
of interventions and others do not and
this is over time and this is what I
meant when I said reality Centric AI
this may not sound cool but when you
play a game of again go or this thing
it's very obvious because the game is
played with very clear rules if I think
about folding proteins the rules again
are clear they are physics and biology
but in this case there are a lot of
interlaced factors and incentives that
are corrupting the data so we need to be
very careful when we use data our
interventions have been made not to
propagate wrong decisions
but the pandemic shows us that we do and
we know we cannot do this with our
industry so what we need to find is the
the fair and the the proper channels and
stakeholders interdisciplinary
stakeholders to regulate in which the
industry can pay the contribution on the
regulation because manufacturing is a
problem okay a pandemic has said so on
behalf of the crystal manufacture it's
not only about AI I can't produce any I
think but you can't really produce it
it's not going to be translating
benefits anywhere so so we need to find
that balance and an industry is
important to take on board it's it's
basically it is difficult but it should
try and the bias is it's nothing new
because medicine is being generated
since hypocrite this time this biases
assist and most of the evidence-based
medicine in a way or another is trying
to deal with that no perfect it's
impossible perfectly but it's safety at
the end of the day the buyers will serve
with it as some minority groups will not
be represented therefore they will
suffer necessity events for example okay
and and it is important
definitely I'm also foreign
and I think actually industry is very
aware of that but I think we still need
to be careful and make sure that with
industry we are thinking carefully about
these problems absolutely thank you both
very much thank you Don um just on these
questions of biases which is clearly a
very important uh aspect
um one of the things you were you were
talking about is the
um the potential for bias in in human
intervention so you know clinicians
having a fixed preconceived ideas to
who's going to benefit what kind of
Lifestyles and things might be
prioritized
um do you see it possible that the the
more expansive use of AI May overcome
some of those human biases
it's a fantastic question as a matter of
fact this is exactly one of the
important areas of research that I do so
I do a lot of work on exactly this
particular area I coined an unhelpful
word called quantitative epistemology to
allow for that but so what was the word
again
quantitative epistemology I
work a lot with clinicians and
exclusively a lot of transplant doctors
both in United States as well as in
Europe in the UK and we know that for
instance historically women have been
transplanted much less they were
considered to be not strong enough to be
weaker and this is one of the main
examples where I encountered and it took
decades for this bias to be removed and
what we have been building is technology
that is trying to look at so there is
some variation in practice that is
desirable because we have different ages
different genders different
characteristics so there's desire
variation practice but it is also what
my clinical colleagues called undesired
variation in practice where biases and
maybe wrong judgments are made and what
we are developing together with
clinicians in three different continents
is exactly this type of technology that
tries to see what is undesirable bias
and try to accelerate the adoption of
Technologies and in particular we have
written some recent work where we show
that if these technologies that we are
building which are actually quite
complex machine learning models we would
have identified
probably 10 years earlier from the data
that humans could have been transplanted
for heart surgery earlier and I think
that these are exciting technology so
you're right
but it is complex because the data that
we have encodes knowledge and expertise
and positive biases but also negative
biases and disentangling the two can
only be done by building careful
technology in collaboration with human
experts and a diversity of human experts
because that's very clear but because
that comes from academic environment
that doesn't mean that doesn't need to
be regulated I come back to it so that
is important so the best example today
is let's make it simple so this is
next day I have to be never been but
I've been called to be a RGB in Tower
hamlets
so this AI systems if they are done
nationally actually internationally the
consist of homogenization in some
aspects can allow that transition to
this new clinician in that to say Hey
you were not paying attention to these
things because you are by a population
set you can is again augmentation of
clinical care so the individual have
augmentation and and it's clear that dab
will benefit a lot of of different
settings because some minorities are
representing one setting and knowing
another okay and what I want to say
there is you know so much that we are
going to build technology that is going
to say Hey you are biased and is going
to make where the clinician potentially
to debug their own thinking process and
more or less to ponder different aspects
just because we are women doesn't
necessarily that we are going to be
weaker so so just being
um let them Ponder and showing related
examples from related cases locally and
internationally because one of the
challenges
that we saw was that actually in some
centers they were seeing very few
sub-populations with certain
characteristics so they didn't have much
experience so they were afraid for
instance to act but the overall uh
information from the globe existed so
what I'm after is not definitely not
replacing clinicians but providing them
these tools such that they can ponder
different
um choices that they have and provide
them evidence and then let them of
course make the final decision together
with the patient fun work to do just
a black box on top of a black box when
we're talking about palantir and
mentioned how and and
um personality you've mentioned how why
would you were that we haven't that
we've put in all of our eggs in one
basket with this one company
just touching up on on this bias
um
in the palantir black box that could be
full of all kinds of biases that we
don't know about right okay so that is
actually a problem that's the reason why
I think we need to have a lot more open
source yeah such that and we need as a I
would say as a country invest in open
source software such that many different
companies and many different groups can
inspect this both data as well as
technologies that are built and we can
get stronger together is foreign
is we need the tools to deal with that
because I can make open source the code
the code changes so there are a lot of
Technology we need to implement with
this okay let me Ledger Technologies Etc
and and whether how the system is
changeable these things are sometimes
and monolithic sometimes they are active
so I don't think open source is just
solve the problem completely you can
because when I go and put a drug for
example let's say the image array yes
they they see everything but that drug
is not open so I don't know this I don't
know the source components of the Pfizer
vaccine for example the nanotechnology
but the regulator knows okay so that is
more efficient than me putting
the the components of that thing open
source because you know it's going to be
it's conditionedness might be condition
necessary but not sufficient to achieve
what you said because we got open source
because open source for many years
journals strive on open source Etc you
misunderstand my point
my point is I think the misunderstand is
not about it's about putting the AI
software that companies like palantir
and others are using internally and
getting let's say not scrutinize what
I'm saying is I would like to see a lot
more investment by the government in
open source AI software which is which
can be used as a platform for other
companies to build their knowledge on
and it is transparent to everyone and
can allow many companies to flourish on
top of this platform rather than putting
everything in a company that doesn't
share their software
very good well let's be very grateful
for that discussion the um the the
purpose of the inquiry is the future
governance of AI so these questions are
very relevant uh very grateful professor
vadasara and Professor Fernandez Reyes
for your evidence today and that
concludes this meeting of the committee
order